Now that you've had your refresher on accuracy,
which of course you're well familiar with from earlier in this class.
We're going to talk about some other evaluation metrics that might be a little
bit more specific depending on what you want to be doing with your machine
learning algorithm.
>> In many cases in real life you care about certain outcomes more than others.
We have an Asymmetry.
For example, if you write a cancer detection test.
I would argue care more about that the cancer gets detected.
Even if you tolerate, occasionally,
false detection, than overlooking cancer which could be disastrous for you.
That's a case where your performance metric favors one type
of error differently from another type of error.
>> So depending on the metric you use it can help you really zero in on
what types of mistakes you might be making.
And you can tune your algorithm for
exactly what you want it to be optimized for.
>> And it's really important you know about this and
apply it because otherwise you might not like your results.